so uh this video is going to be titled
treat your business like your second
child so knowing that I have a lot of
young fans this may not resonate but for
all of you older peeps like me that are
lucky enough to have two children
something interesting happened the other
day we had some great friends over Erin
and Francois they have three children
and Erin was getting their little
child's ready and their third child was
pink on the ground she's like flailing
in the air and then I was thinking about
how Lizzie and I are handling sander
compared to Misha and I realized my god
like I asked Erin I said Erin would you
ever let Sebastian be like that and
she's like absolutely not and just not
realizing in a very common joke around
people that have done children is how
differently you acted the second child
or the third child then you get the
first first one micromanage everything
every video tape its first fart it's six
day it's six day and three weeks after
the first time it never sneezed on a
Tuesday and everything is focused on
everything is micromanage everything is
over thought I have been paying
attention to a lot of people running
businesses and from corporate America
that wants every little bar ally tight
to entrepreneurs that have never been
through it before
thus are micromanaging dumb [ __ ] that
actually doesn't matter it's very
obvious to me that the best piece of
advice I could give it at this moment in
this world that where I want to do some
outdoor content these days because I
haven't been doing these videos is treat
your business like a second child
nothing is perfect nothing in business
is black and white all the magic is in
the gray have patience nothing is the
worst thing that ever happened and
nothing is the best thing that ever
happened celebrating way you've raised
money is just the beginning being
devastated thinking it's over when you
lost the deal is not the true reality
it's always somewhere in the middle and
if you understand how to raise a second
child to realize the differences
cool it's eating dirt over there little
Timmy's eating dirt and that's okay but
you would have never left big sister
can't do that that's the same way I
think you need to look at your business
nothing is the end of the world and
nothing is the greatest thing of all
time embracing the chaos embracing the
nimbleness embracing the things that you
can't control is the complete definition
of a leader that is going to be able to
navigate through the chaotic never
predictable business world so relax grab
a coffee take a shot of vodka it's all
gonna be okay
treat your business like a second child